veamos si podemos dividir entre números
más grandes hay que te voy a advertir
primero debes saber las tablas de
multiplicar mínimo desde la desde la del
1 hasta la del 10
entonces saber uno por uno o dos por
tres todas esas hasta 10 por 10 que es
igual a 100 y cuando yo estaba en la
escuela cuando yo estaba en la escuela
llegamos a aprendernos hasta la del 12
por 12 o sea la del 12 12 por 2 es igual
a 144 y bueno a mí a mí con la del 10 me
basta simplemente aprender telas y ahora
sí ya vamos a dividir supongamos que yo
tengo el número 25 y quiero quiero
dividir este número entre 5 podría yo
dibujar 25 objetos y dividirlos en
grupos de 5 o 5 grupos y ver cuántos
elementos hay en cada grupo aunque la
manera más fácil de hacer esto la manera
más sencilla de pensar en esto es 5 x
que es igual a 25 5 x que es igual a 25
si te sabes las tablas del 5 entonces
sabes que 5 por 5 es igual a 25
así que inmediatamente por tu
conocimiento de las tablas de
multiplicar sabes que 5 le cabe al 25
exactamente 5 veces escribe 5 aquí
arriba y no sobre el 2 entonces debes
tener cuidado con la notación 5 le cabe
al 25 exactamente 5 veces y lo mismo si
yo digo si yo digo 7 caben en 49 cuantas
veces cuantas veces veamos es como decir
7 x porque es igual a 49 7 por rayita en
blanco y en el espacio si te sale la
tabla de multiplicar del 7 sabes que 7
por 7 es igual a 49 así que aquí va el 7
y los ejemplos que he hecho hasta este
momento son números multiplicados por si
mismo haré otro ejemplo entonces 9 le
cabe cabe en 54 cuántas veces si no no
tiene memorizado puedes decir 9 por 5 es
igual a 45 9 por 6 es igual a 45 más 9
lo cual es igual
a 54 por lo tanto 9 le cabe el 54
exactamente 6 veces porque 9 por 6 es
igual a 54 y ahí va entonces un 6 así
que es importante memorizar las tablas
de multiplicar desde la del 1 hasta la
del 10 mínimo para saber o para poder
resolver estos problemas que son algo
sencillos y se resuelven de manera
rápida ahora vamos a intentar otros
problemas que quizás requieran más de
más del simple hecho de saber las tablas
de multiplicar digamos que yo tengo
digamos que yo tengo yo y digamos que yo
quiero dividir yo quiero dividir 43
entre 3 baja entonces quiero dividir 43
entre 3 esto esto es mayor que 3 por 10
o 3 por 12 aunque o bueno mejor mejor
voy a hacer otra cosa ok perfecto que yo
creo que a lo que voy a hacer es dividir
23 entre 33 si te sabes de tabla de
multiplicar del 3 entonces sabes que no
hay un número que multiplicado por tres
desde exactamente 23 aquí tres por una
33 por 26
3 x 3 9 12 15 18 21 y 24 lo ves no hay
un número 23 aquí en los múltiplos de 3
entonces cómo resolvemos esto lo que
debes hacer es pensar pensar en el mayor
múltiplo de 3 que cabe en 23 entonces
ese sería el 21 3 de cabe al 21
exactamente siete veces porque 3 por 7
es igual a 21 entonces 3 caben el 23 7
veces pero pero no exactamente porque 7
por 3 es igual a 21 así que tendremos un
residuo 23 menos 21
esto nos da esto nos da un residuo de 2
entonces podemos escribir podemos
escribir 23 dividido entre 3 es igual a
77 residuo voy a poner la palabra
completa residuo 2
y aquí puedes ver que no tiene por qué
ser exacto pero pero puedes ver que cabe
perfectamente siete veces eso nos lleva
a 21 y nos da un residuo de 2 puedes
trabajar con problemas de división donde
no tienes exactamente un múltiplo del
número por el cual estás dividiendo pero
bueno vamos a practicar con números de
mayores cifras y creo así te darás
cuenta de lo que está de lo que está
pasando en el universo de la división
entonces hagamos esto con un número más
grande vamos a dividido voy a dividir
algo muy grande entre 4
digamos que 344 dividido entre 4
inmediatamente tú ves esto y dice solo
espera un momento porque yo solamente me
sé las tablas de hasta el 10 entonces y
4 por 12 es igual a 48 esto es un número
mucho mayor que ese así que bueno pero
pero observa esto es este sencillo solo
debes saber tu tabla del 4 para poder
resolver este problema 4 cuántas veces
le cabe al número 3
veamos piensa en esto piensa en esto
es un número menor que el 4 cierto
entonces el 4 como va a caber en un
número menor que el no es posible así
que el 4 le cabe en el número 30 veces
no en ninguna no no se puede simplemente
así que ahora vamos con lo siguiente
vamos ahora con el número 34 con el
número 34 4 cuántas veces le cabe al
número 34 a ok aquí debes saber tus
tablas de multiplicar del 4
tenemos que 4 por 8 4 por 8 es igual a
32 y 4 por 9 es igual a 36 como puedes
ver le cabe al 34 36 ya se pasó entonces
le cabe a 34 8 veces y va a quedar que
dará un recibo un pequeño residuo
entonces 4 le cabe al 34 8 veces y para
encontrar el residuo veamos aquí debes
notar que estoy hablando de 344 le cabe
a 340 80 veces escribí el 8 en el lugar
de los decimales entonces bueno solo por
habilidad o por hacer la cosa más
decimos 4 caben 34 8 veces pero ok aquí
aquí 8 debe estar en lugar de los
decimales 8 por 4 es igual a 32 entonces
hacemos la resta 34 menos 32 es igual a
ese es el residuo y aquí el 2 está en la
columna de los decimales ajá esta es la
columna de los decimales como puedes ver
así que lo que en realidad estamos
haciendo es decir que 4 caben 340 80
veces 80 por 4 es igual a 320 entonces
hay de hecho aquí y aquí está mal esta
línea porque solamente voy a borrar esto
es que parecía un 12 ahora ya es un 2 es
un 2 entonces tenemos residuo 20 porque
el 2 está en en la columna de los
decimales y ahora voy a bajar este 4 lo
bajo para para dividir para dividir el
344 entre 4 y pensamos en esto entonces
ok vamos a pensar 4
cuántas veces cabe en 344 cabe 80 veces
pero va va a tener un recibo de 24
entonces cuántas veces cabe el 4 en 24
sabemos qué que 4 por 6 es igual a 24
ajá entonces 24 dividido entre 4 es
igual a 6 ponemos aquí en el lugar de
las unidades el 6 6 por 4 es igual a 24
hacemos la resta y no no hay residuo
porque 24 menos 24 es igual a 0
así que 4 caben 344 exactamente 86 veces
si tú tomas 344 objetos digamos manzanas
entonces queremos repartir las en
costales
así que 344 manzanas y las dividen en
grupos de 4 tendrás 86 costales entonces
lo que llegamos otro ejemplo 91 entre 7
una vez más
7 x 12 es igual a 84 91 es mayor que 84
pero usamos el mismo sistema 7 cuántas
veces le cabe al 97 le cabe al 9 una vez
1 por 7 es igual a 7 y 9 menos 7 es
igual a 2 entonces tenemos aquí 2 y
bajamos el 1
ahí está entonces bajamos al 1 y nos
queda 21 pero aún no terminamos esto
esto puede parecer magia pero no lo ves
solamente lo que estamos haciendo es
decir que 7 caben 90 10 veces 10 por 7
es igual a 70 puedes poner aquí el ceros
y si lo deseas
91 - 70 es igual a 21 entonces 7 cabe en
91 10 veces y queda residuo 21 y luego 7
caben 21 tú sabes que 7 por 3 es igual a
21 entonces tenemos que tenemos que 21
menos 21 es igual a 0
ese es el residuo residuo cero por lo
tanto 91 dividido entre 7 es
a 13 hagamos otro ejemplo otro ejemplo
un poco más directo ya sin tanta
explicación porque lo que me interesa es
que entiendas el proceso eso es lo
importante
hagamos uno con digamos que siete no
mejor siete no porque es un número que
he estado usando mucho voy a usar mejor
el 8 al que le sigue entonces el 8 a ver
qué te parece 608 dividido entre 8 8
caben 608 cuántas veces 8 caben 6
cuántas veces ha ninguna porque el 6 es
menor que el 8 entonces sigo 8 caben 60
en 60 cuántas veces voy a separar esto
porque un necesito espacio entonces 8
caben 60 cuántas veces 8 x 7 es igual a
56 luego 8 por 8 es igual a 64
por lo tanto 8 caben 60 64 se pasa
entonces cabe en en 67 veces 8 caben 67
veces y quedará un residuo
entonces 8 camino 67 veces y al 7 lo
pongo en el lugar de las centésimas como
puedes ver porque estoy estoy dividiendo
al 67 por 8 es igual a 56 60 menos 56
hago la resta y aquí aquí obtenemos
entonces 4 un residuo de 4 después
bajamos al 8 baja entonces 8 cabe en 48
cuantas veces ocho por seis cuánto es
eso es igual a exactamente 48 perfecto
ok entonces 8 caben 48 6 veces
aquí 8 x 6 es igual a 48 hacemos la
resta y nos queda un residuo de 0
perfecto ahora espero ya con esto tengas
un poco más de ilusión y en tiendas como
como dividimos números de más cifras
la magia está en en saber las tablas de
multiplicar es la base de todo
aprenderte las tablas de multiplicar
bien nos vemos pronto